opposition leaders in belarus have
welcomed a decision
by eu leaders to reject the results of
the election
that kept president alexander lukashenko
in power
eu heads also announced sanctions
against a large number of individuals
involved in alleged voting fraud and
violence against protesters
this is not lunchtime or the end of a
shift
this is another nail in the coffin of
lukashenko's credibility
workers walk out of a state-run
chemicals factory
threats have no power over them anymore
protesters urged workers at one of the
country's famed tractor factories to
join them
but some decided to keep their jobs
these miners were already outside at a
rally
across the industrial heartlands of
belarus
rejection of lukashenko's regime has
gone nationwide
and on wednesday that rejection
officially went international
a clear message from the european union
we are ready to accompany peaceful
democratic transition of power in
belarus
germany's angela merkel has spoken with
russia's putin
but said lukashenko wouldn't take her
calls
one can only mediate if one is in
contact with all sides
but we will do everything we can from
our side to promote a national dialogue
in lukashenko security council meeting
the talk was
of no talk the leaders of the western
countries offer us negotiations
conversations
and at this time they continue to push
their line we can see it we understand
it
but we do not accept it i want them to
hear that
but those filling the streets across
belarus day and night are desperate for
dialogue
one of their leaders told dw they want
everyone to help
if it's possible that the eu states the
russian federation and ukraine can help
us to organize a dialogue within the
country
and with external partners so that a
transfer of power happens
and we listen to each other i would
always support it
this is a decisive moment for us
decisive not only because putin has
remained tight-lipped
but decisive because they have the
support of the european union
and decisive because now their fear has
gone
and for more let's bring in
correspondent nick connolly who is
joining us
from minsk nick what is the atmosphere
among protesters do they
sense change in the air
well you definitely get a sense that
people have lost their fear fear of
coming out in the streets
um simply because there are so many of
them i think there's a feeling that the
regime here can't put all of them in
jail having said that there has been
significant violence protesters spending
days in
uh prison in detention about 30 people
still unaccounted for days after they
were taken in
but people are coming out are voicing
their dissatisfaction to regime in a way
that was unthinkable just a few weeks
ago
think about these protests they're very
diffused there is no central protest
camp these protests
um erupt all across minsk and all across
the country and disappear as quickly
as they begin i think this is part of
the strategy to make it more
difficult for the security services here
to come after people
and to detain them but there is a real
sense that this is
far from over this is the beginning
rather than the end of a process
of uh coming out and uh voicing their
dissatisfaction after 26 years with just
one president
and what kind of reaction has there been
to the planned european sanctions
well yesterday on the main square here
in minsk you
were aware of thousands of protesters
were out for yet another protest in
front of the government buildings
there was a sense that people had taken
this uh to notice they were happy to
realize that europe
is watching and paying attention to
these protests i think it's more a
symbolic step
it shows that europe is solidarity to an
extent with them without making any
particularly
strong promises i think in terms of
practical influence on the regime here
i don't think it will make that much of
a difference lukashenko has been
under sanctions time and time again and
those sanctions have then been withdrawn
without him doing much in return
i think alexander lukchenko's government
will affected those in but definitely on
the
symbol on the the kind of gesture
politics side of things that was
important step for people here on the
streets to know that they are
being watched and that the events here
are being followed nick bring us up to
date
on where russia stands in all of this
because
it has traditionally been a very close
ally of lukashenkos
exactly i mean belarus is russia's
closest ally they
are currently so-called union states
they have a kind of
loose uh association which russia has
always wanted to deepen to further
integrate belarus
into effectively one country with russia
um
president lexington has spoken to
vladimir putin several times this week
and been assured of russia's willingness
to
support him should events escalate here
um i think it's a difficult uh game for
lukashenko because he has tried to
resist
full integration with russia he fears
that russia will effectively take over
and he will be left maybe only as some
symbolic
figurehead the russians for now are not
saying that they will bring in troops
they are
supporting the lukashenko regime with
advisers bella russian state tv
yesterday
it was reported that many of the local
journalists have been replaced with
russian journalists
because the locals were no longer loyal
to the regime so i think it's about
deniable support for the lukashenko
regime
not russian tanks out in the streets of
mint but instead stuff that
you know events and support through
people and resources that can shore up
this regime without
bringing that high diplomatic cost for
the kremlin without coming out in kind
of full-scale
support with boots on the ground as it
were that is what we're going to see in
the next
days and weeks okay so it's all very
covert at this point dw's nick connolly
with the view from minsk
thank you nick